[Music]
good evening
I'm just coming from a bilateral meeting
with President Biden it was a very good
meeting very constructive we discussed a
lot of topics
I want to
emphasize four different topics here the
first topic we discussed is the
inflation reduction Act
and indeed we welcome the inflation
reduction act because it is a massive
investment in the green transition
moving towards a net zero economy
it is mirrored by the green deal
industrial plan in the European Union
had already an agreement
the American market
today we agreed that we will work on
critical raw materials that have been
sourced or processed in the European
Union and to give them the access to the
American Market as if they were sourced
in the American Market we will work on
an agreement what that is concerned and
the third point is that we agreed on a
transparency dialogue concerning the
incentives that are giving given to the
clean tech industry for us is important
on both sides of the Atlantic to know
what kind of incentives are being given
to the cleantech industry to make sure
that we join forces to boost the clean
tech industry that is crucial and
Paramount for reaching a circular
economy a net zero economy
the second topic I want to mention is
Russia's atrocious war in Ukraine of
course we have extensively discussed
that
starting with the financial budget
support that the European Union is
giving 18 billion during this year one
and a half billion per month to Ukraine
but also
discussing the way we are caring for
four million refugees from Ukraine in
the European Union a strong Focus was on
the question of sanctions as you know we
have issued 10 biting packages of
sanctions here now the focus is on
enforcement and on preventing
circumvention this is a topic that is
for us very important and of course the
overarching message is we will stand by
Ukraine for as long as it takes
the third topic that we've been
discussing discussing is economic
security
also in preparation of the G7 leaders
meeting in Hiroshima with the Japanese
presidency and last but certainly not
least we've discussed the topic of
people to people
um connection between the European Union
and the United States
as we know the best foundation for
long-lasting partnership and deep
friendship are the people themselves the
more young people students academics are
crossing the Atlantic and being on the
other side of the Atlantic the better
better the relationship between the
European Union and the United States
also for decades to come here we want to
emphasize on the experience we have with
the Fulbright stipends and with Erasmus
on the European side how we can step up
this topic and improve that topic
[Music]
yes we have agreed that we will start
work now with a clear goal the goal is
to have an agreement on critical raw
materials that have been sourced or
processed in the European Union
that these strategic Supply chains are
able to access the American Market as if
they had been sourced in the United
States so also access to all the
necessary benefits from the United
States
the Chinese experience
can you be a little bit
I think this is a bilateral matter of
the respective countries
[Music]
I think for us it's very important that
on this topic We join forces because it
is crucial
for our future for fighting climate
change and limiting global warming so
for us was and is important that we join
forces that we are complementary that we
boost the respective cleantech industry
on both sides and I think this we
achieve now also with the three steps
electric vehicles access to the American
Market the critical raw materials
strengthen the supply chains and the
transparency Dialogue on incentives on
both sides of the Atlantic
[Music]
we touched upon the topic briefly indeed
it is very important that the Serbia
Kosovo dialogue continues
um it is not easy they are still a lot
of issues to solve but it's moving in
the right direction and full support
from both our sides to that dialogue
[Music]
there's a good plan on the table
um there is a road map how to get there
so we expect and hope that both will be
very constructive
thank you very much thank you thank you
[Music]